مقطع فيديو متداول على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لرده فعل غير متوقعه من ناقه
رات صاحبها بعد غيابه عنها بسبب مرضه
نتابع
[موسيقى]
بعد انتشار مقطع فيديو لرقصه الحب على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي امام احد المعالم
الرئيسيه في طهران النظام النظام الايراني
يحكم بالسجن 10 سنوات ونصف السنه على شابه
وخطيبها وكلاهما في عمر العشرين ومنعهما
من السفر وحضر نشاطهما على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بتهمه الاخلال بالامن القومي
والتشجيع على الفساد وممارسه الفحشاء
[موسيقى]
مقطع فيديو اثار جدلا واسعا على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي في مصر لمطعم
المهرجانات المصريه حمو بيكا وهو ينصر
الاف الاموال على مطرب شهير في حفل زفاف
نشاهد
[موسيقى]
قطع برص مصري مسافه تقدر بثلاثه الاف ميل
لينتقل من موطنه الاصلي في مصر الى مدينه
مانشستر في بريطانيا ويستقر داخل علبه
فراوله في رحله تعد الاغرب من نوعها ولم
يكن يخطر في بالي سيده بريطانيه وهي تفتح
باب ثلاجتها انها ستجد حيوانا صغيرا يطل
عليها من علبه الفراوله التي اشترتها من
السوبر ماركت واحتفت وسائل اعلام بريطانيه
بواقعه البرص حتى وصلت الجمعيه الملكيه
لمنع القسوه على الحيوانات وفحصه طبيب
بيطري مختص في الحيوانات الغريبه ليؤكد
انه بصحه جيده رغم الرحله الطويله التي
قطعها
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء